[Musique]
et bienvenue sur la page LinkedIn TV 78
pour une émission spéciale consacrée à
l'emploi une émission en collaboration
avec le Centre de Formation numérique
Star Trek et justement durant cette
émission Virginie févé nous accompagnera
bonjour Alors Virginie d'abord un mot
cette émission est rendue possible parce
que cette semaine vous avez accompagné
des candidates
des candidats pour postuler et booster
leur employabilité grâce à l'outil
numérique exactement un programme d'une
semaine en partenariat avec Pôle emploi
la CPME 78 et TV 78 et voilà et puis
chose exceptionnelle durant cette
émission il y aura de véritables en tout
cas des petits entretiens des prises de
contact des entretiens d'embauche entre
les candidates et certains recruteurs et
dirigeants d'entreprises nous
retrouverons juste après notamment trois
candidates Morgan Collin
qui viendront nous raconter donc leur
semaine et puis ensuite et bien
postuleront à certains postes
[Musique]
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi a
baissé de près de 8 % dans les Yvelines
en 2022 mais les besoins en recrutement
reste toujours important et mettre
parfois les entreprises en difficulté
alors comment assurer ses recrutements
en 2023 pour en parler en plateau avec
nous Kira et drief bonjour
directrice du bureau de Pôle emploi de
Rambouillet kendji gifenju dirigeant de
RDI manager bonjour Kévin nous avons
aussi Yann Roland dirigeant de xéphy
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bonjour
bonjour Jean-Paul Mignard dirigeant
daxol à Trappes
dirigeante de star tags centre de
formation dédiées au numérique à leur
première question je le disais tout à
l'heure les entreprises en contre
certaines difficultés il y a une étude
qui est sortie c'est près de 80%
d'entreprises de dirigeantes en tout cas
qui disent que et ben c'est leur
principale difficulté dans un contexte
qu'on connaît à l'heure actuelle il y a
les prix d'énergie qui augmentent il y a
d'autres sujets aussi et des
incertitudes liés à la crise sanitaire
qui se poursuit et pourtant c'est les
problèmes de recrutement la principale
préoccupation les dit en tant que
dirigeant d'entreprise que vous êtes
Yann Jean-Paul et Kevin qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez dire concernant vos
recrutements c'est tout à fait ça en
fait c'est une partie intégrante de
notre journée de notre quotidien de
recruter des de chercher en fait sur des
sur les plateformes les bons candidats
et de d'essayer de les attirer et puis
aussi après les fidéliser dans notre
secteur dans l'informatique le marché
particulièrement tendu et les candidats
reçoivent beaucoup beaucoup de
sollicitations donc on a besoin de de
passer du temps sur les plateformes pour
essayer de trouver les meilleurs profils
oui parce que faut dire que c'est 50 ans
en Yvelines et spécialisée dans la
distribution de produits informatiques
et assurer aussi les services
informatiques vous Jean-Paul miner c'est
la distribution de d'infrastructures
dédiées aux personnes à mobilité réduite
en quoi vous êtes touché par ces
difficultés de recrutement nos
difficultés de recrutement sont
principalement sur sur des postes qui
sont moins gérés moi technique que ceux
de l'anglais de chez exécistes et
apprendre demande pas des capacités et
des grandes connaissances techniques
mais les difficultés que nous avons
c'est sur des postes opérationnels type
commercial type livreur techniciens
d'atelier etc ou ce qu'on recherche
c'est plutôt des profils et des états
d'esprit de de personnes des personnes
qui ont l'envie de s'investir et l'envie
de travailler les compétences pour les
apporte on est là pour les pour les
aborder pour les appeler et la
difficulté elle est surtout là vous
Kevin vous êtes dans le management de
l'innovation
globalement c'est une activité numérique
en quoi vous êtes touché par ce sujet
parce que c'est numérique on le sait
c'est un métier en tension oui
effectivement c'est un métier en tension
nous sommes touchés par cette réalité il
faut au niveau du recrutement je rejoins
mon confrère des effets en ce sens que
on a l'impression d'avoir une réalité
paradoxal on a besoin de de diplômés de
jeunes talentueux et sur le marché il y
a des jeunes qui en chaise mais on
n'arrive pas à se marcher ensemble
pourquoi j'ai du mal à comprendre
peut-être qu'un besoin de formation on
en discutera tout à l'heure mais on a
vraiment un réel problème de recruter
des jeunes dans le domaine du numérique
des développeurs et puis des consultants
innovations c'est du technique mais on a
des talents en France il faudrait qu'on
arrive à se trouver et on va en parler
justement on parle bien évidemment vous
l'avez dit un de formation numérique
avec Virginie mais d'abord justement
arriver à matcher qui ira je me tourne
vers vous directrice de Pôle emploi de
Rambouillet est-ce que vous pourriez me
décrire un peu la conjoncture sur le
marché de l'emploi est-ce qu'elle est
inédite aujourd'hui ce qu'on connaît
actuellement alors oui elle est inédite
c'est vrai que la demande d'emploi a
baissée de manière significative ou
disiez plus de 8% depuis ce début
d'année dans le même temps on a une
augmentation très significative
également des projets de recrutement
enfin des embauches qui ont augmenté
depuis ce début d'année depuis 17%. un
taux de chômage dans les Yvelines qui
qui est totalement autour des 6%, 6,3%.
donc de détention sur le marché du
travail effectivement un écart entre les
compétences disponibles sur le marché du
travail et les compétences recherchées
par les recruteurs
comment on peut répondre à ça mais c'est
notre quotidien à Pôle Emploi notre
sujet c'est bien d'agir sur ces tensions
de recrutement et nous avons
700 collaborateurs sur les Yvelines et
70 chargées de relations entreprises et
on renforce encore aujourd'hui nos
équipes pour accompagner les projets de
recrutement des entreprises et proposer
des solutions adaptées à chaque
difficulté donc on a en fait une
stratégie à deux mailles
avec une stratégie impactante sur le
marché du travail avec une orientation
d'achat de formation pour pouvoir
développer suffisamment de compétences
disponibles sur le marché du travail et
également un bouquet de service où là on
est en capacité d'aller davantage dans
du sur-mesure et accompagner chaque
entreprise et proposer une solution
adaptée à son projet de recrutement
on vient de voir des images de rugby
alors je tiens à le préciser Pôle emploi
et le rugby sont liés parce qu'en fait
vous avez une initiative innovante de
recruter du stade vers l'emploi l'idée
c'est de faire rencontrer recruteur et
candidats à travers le sport finalement
je me tourne vers les dirigeants
justement vous seriez prêt à jouer au
rugby avec un futur collaborateur ou pas
ça dépend de la taille du collaborateur
en question ça dépend ce qu'on appelle
jouer avec mais en tout cas oui ce sont
des profits qui nous intéressent
beaucoup d'ailleurs notre groupe en fait
défi est très très accès par le vers le
sport santé sport qui est important chez
nous avec des coachs en interne donc
effectivement c'est des profils qui nous
intéressent recrutés par le sport
Jean-Paul et Kevin rugby volontiers je
dirais très volontiers ce qui est
surtout intéressant c'est de au-delà
au-delà d'un CV c'est d'aller découvrir
le tempérament et l'envie de la personne
c'est ça qui est plus important et
l'esprit d'équipe parce que c'est
vraiment les fondamental pour
l'intégration dans nos entreprises on
reparlera de ces fameux soft skills mais
d'abord forcément les compétences la
formation Virginie ça c'est votre
spécialité
durant la semaine vous avez accompagné
des candidats pour booster justement
leur employabilité à travers l'outil
numérique en quoi aujourd'hui l'outil
numérique est indispensable pour trouver
un emploi et même pour les entreprises
essayer de trouver le bon collaborateur
en fait on les a accompagnés sur un
programme chaque jour avec une
thématique différente l'idée c'était
d'apprendre à raconter son histoire
parce que on a tous une belle histoire à
raconter encore faut-il savoir se vendre
et en tout cas bien la raconter parfois
on a peu de temps pour convaincre
d'ailleurs aussi savoir communiquer sur
les réseaux sociaux est-ce que c'est
vrai que c'est une vraie problématique
aujourd'hui
on peut on peut ne être visible et donc
l'idée c'était de leur montrer qu'on
peut vraiment exister avoir de la
visibilité grâce à LinkedIn on les a
accompagne également avec des outils
comme quand va pour refaire quand on va
pour refaire leur CV habiller un peu
leur profil pour que ce soit bien plus
marketé parce qu'en fait c'est vraiment
ça et surtout leur faire prendre
conscience qu'en fait la communication
séminaire de la guerre aujourd'hui il
faut se rendre visible des bons
employeurs il faut cibler sa recherche
pas peine de taper partout et très large
mais en tout cas en ayant les bonnes
techniques ça a fonctionné parce qu'on
parlera du bilan mais en tout cas on est
très contents
tous ces candidats en tout cas les
candidats qui ont suivi le programme on
décrochait un entretien donc cette
semaine donc en quatre jours finalement
tous ont eu des prises de contact donc
entre 1 et 3 employeurs minimum on va
les suivre pendant trois semaines encore
donc le problème s'arrête pas là mais on
se rend compte qu'effectivement elles
ont pris conscience que finalement
parfois avec un poste on pouvait taguer
un bon employeur et se rendre visible et
attirer l'attention et du coup ouvrir le
dialogue et donc c'est plateforme de
candidature finalement c'est pas un
envoi de CV simple c'est ouvrir une
discussion et montrer qu'on a l'intérêt
et montrer qu'on s'intéresse au sujet
prouver en fait par l'exemplarité que
voilà c'est notre sujet et c'est nous la
bonne personne quoi donc effectivement
c'est très bien fonctionné très content
depuis le début de l'émission communique
et matcher essayer de me faire matcher
un poste avec un bon collaborateur et là
je me tourne vers vous quiera par
rapport à Pôle Emploi comment justement
améliorer tout ça et quels sont les
méthodes peut-être innovantes que vous
allez mettre en place en 2023 au niveau
de Pôle emploi alors c'est pour suivre
les opérations du stade vers l'emploi
vous disiez que vous étiez effectivement
en recherche de profil des opérations
telles que le stade vers l'emploi donne
l'opportunité à un candidat de démontrer
des qualités professionnelles des
qualités relationnelles comme la
capacité à travailler en équipe la
capacité à interagir avec avec
des candidats qui sont là
capacités également à respecter des
consignes à faire preuve de persévérance
de se positionner comme un leader donc
ces opérations permettent effectivement
de sortir un peu de cet entretien un peu
formel qui peut être anxiogène pour
certains candidats donc on poursuit ces
opérations et puis c'est toute notre
ingénierie recrutement que l'on mobilise
au quotidien pour les entreprises ça
peut aller de l'analyse de poste pour
accompagner notamment des petites
structures dans la qualification de
leurs besoins anticiper sur les
problématiques de recrutement en
confrontant au marché du travail et
derrière c'est toute l'ingénierie autour
de comment on va pouvoir proposer des
solutions pour adapter des candidats à
des besoins à vos profils de poste et
également notre offre de service s'est
enrichie depuis le mois de septembre
avec une ingénierie formation pour
accompagner et aider les entreprises TPE
PME qui rencontre des difficultés de
recrutement pour construire un parcours
de formation un parcours d'adaptation et
donc ce sont toutes ces solutions qui
qui vont permettre agir sur les tensions
de recrutement après il y a un une
condition de réussite c'est
l'anticipation plus vite on mobilise nos
services et plus vite effectivement on
est en capacité de poser un diagnostic
de projeter sur des solutions et
mobiliser notre réseau pour vous
accompagner alors justement puisque vous
avez des dirigeants quand vous entendez
les propos de Kera comment vous
réagissez est-ce que vous connaissez ces
solutions ces différentes initiatives de
Pôle emploi en tant que dirigeant et
dans le besoin de nouvelles
collaborateurs en ce qui me concentre
j'en connais quelques unes mais je
connais pas l'étendue de tous les
programmes parce que mon métier c'est
pas d'être un métier de recruteur à
plein temps donc je fais avant tout
dirigeant et entreprises de 40 personnes
donc voilà il y a des activités
quotidiennes qui sont importantes en
tout cas moi mon organisation c'est de
d'être quasiment recrutement permanent
en fait même si on n'a pas un poste
ouvert en tout cas en des annonces qui
passent et dès qu'on voit effectivement
un profil qui nous intéresse c'est tout
de suite essayer de mettre en place de
le contacter puis éventuellement faire
du recrutement donc j'écoutais ce que
vous dit avec attention et c'est vrai
que c'est extrêmement important on a un
candidat quand on soit beaucoup de CV
parfois sur des annonces en soi beaucoup
de CV mais des CV qui correspondent pas
forcément à nos besoins si on a
effectivement un candidat qui va
démontrer l'intérêt pour vous pour votre
activité votre métier effectivement là
ça fait la différence et même on va dire
si coche pas tout à fait toutes les
cases bah en fait l'intérêt va faire que
voilà il va remonter on va dire sur le
haut en fait de la pile en tout cas on
va pouvoir engager cette interaction et
effectivement pour nous c'est c'est
super en fait parce que trouver une
candidature à travers des DCV parfois
qu'on reçoit c'est extrêmement compliqué
on a parfois peu de temps pour pour les
analyser et bah parfois voilà on passe à
côté de d'excellents candidats Kevin
Jean-Paul c'est une réalité que vous
connaissez vous avez pas le temps de de
finalement vous engager pleinement dans
complètement alors moi je gère pas
directement ce que j'ai collaboratrice
qui interviennent dessus on est 18
personnes aujourd'hui et
le retour que j'ai et je vois passer de
temps en temps effectivement c'est on a
95% de CV qu'on reçoit mais qui ne sont
absolument pas adaptés avec des CV ou
des notes de motivation qui sont passés
qui correspondent effectivement à tout
le monde et je m'aperçois que les
déclics que l'on peut avoir c'est
simplement sur une phrase sur un mot sur
quelque chose qui tient ça ça
effectivement ça me correspond et je
dirais que toute l'attention que peut
avoir un candidat et la dernière
recrutement qu'on a eu c'est une
personne qui est qui est arrivé à
l'entretien et qui avait passé du temps
sur notre site internet qui connaissait
les produits presque aussi bien que nous
et qui avait vraiment préparé son
entretien et qu'elle va vraiment envie
de venir et je crois que c'est vraiment
ça c'est manifesté l'envie et quand on
met manifeste cet envie en face j'irai
d'un recruteur il y a 50 plus de 50% du
chemin qui est fait quoi clairement ça
c'est le premier point et le deuxième
point nous dans notre essence puisque on
travaille et on intervient dans dans le
monde du handicap on essaye aussi de
d'enorer également de faire du
recrutement inclusif et en local autour
de sur trappes serait en cours sur la
verrière etc
et donc des personnes qui sont éloignées
de l'ampleur et sur les quartiers et là
notre grosse difficulté j'ai envie d'en
faire plus la grande difficulté c'est
d'arriver à les identifier les trouver
et on ne peut pas passer à temps fou à
solliciter toutes les structures les
associations etc et mon rêve ça serait
d'avoir demain une sorte de guichet
unique dans lequel on dit voilà on a ce
besoin là et une personne qui derrière
dit on profite on va les solliciter tel
endroit tel ou telle personne et nous
faire gagner énormément de temps et
efficacité pour nous mais pour les
candidats aussi c'est celui-ci elles
existent les conseillers en évolution
professionnelle donc qui accompagne les
demandeurs d'emploi dans leur recherche
d'emploi vous avez par exemple à trappe
l'agence le Pôle emploi avec lequel vous
êtes en relation une équipe dédiée pour
l'accompagnement des personnes qui
relèvent des quartiers prioritaires de
la ville également des équipes
qui accompagnent des personnes en
situation de handicap et donc c'est pour
une politique effectivement de
recrutement inclusive les interlocuteurs
des équipe dédiée qui accompagne ces
populations les plus éloignées ou en
fragilité en tout cas pour qui voilà en
se mobilise et on en fait on mobilise
notre offre de service vous pouvez aussi
être en relation avec ses équipes là et
on peut organiser des sessions de
recrutement chaque agence a également
ouvre ses portes aux entreprises pour
les accueillir vous offrir cette tribune
là de communiquer autour de votre
entreprise votre marque employeur vos
projets vos besoins de recrutement et
puis rencontrer des candidats également
donc les sessions de recrutement elle
cesser notre quotidien donc
chaque agence est un lieu d'opportunité
de service donc ces opportunités c'est
aussi cette opportunité de rencontrer
des candidats
avec le Pôle emploi de Trappes pour des
AFPR voilà et plutôt très bien
fonctionné c'est collaboration après je
note deux points tout en étant en accord
avec mes confrères je note deux points
sur ce que Virginie et qui a grandi d'un
côté il y a l'innovation et l'approche
innovante des processus de recrutement
que vous avez ça c'est très important
c'est ce qu'on achète du travail bien
sûr une approche les profils classiques
oui mais on veut des candidats qui
apporte quelque chose en plus tu as une
vision qui ont quelque chose de
d'original qui va vraiment faire le
déclic parce que les profils on en a
plusieurs et en plus des profils qui ne
correspondent pas qui ont donc ça ça
passe toujours mais le deuxième point
c'est au niveau de la communication et
l'outil numérique les candidats c'est un
candidat de plus en plus les contacts
des recruteurs directement il présente
leur profil ceux qui font ce qu'ils
aimeraient faire et le lien avec ce que
nous on fait et ça ça touche ça c'est
déjà le Candia le profil va bien parce
qu'il a étudié et en plus il vous
contacte spontanément et ça ça voilà ça
ça intéresse ça crée la discussion même
si parfois on n'a pas une solution
tout de suite des questions des
problématiques à mettre des stagiaires
ou des jeunes on en a toujours on peut
discuter ensemble et voir ce qu'on peut
faire avec LinkedIn la proximité entre
un patron et finalement un candidat à ne
jamais être aussi intéressantes
c'est-à-dire que on peut directement
c'est plus les process mails comme avant
on peut directement les toucher
directement se rendre visible voilà
c'est une stratégie marketing enfin qui
peut mettre en place et chacun doit le
faire parce que finalement ça fait
partie du jeu je pense aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir trouver le job de ses rêves
parce que trouver un emploi c'est une
chose et puis on le sait pour qu'un
candidat je prends ma casquette
d'employeur mais pour qu'un candidat
perdu et finalement qui puisse évoluer
par la suite il faut qu'il aime ce qu'il
fait enfin son quotidien c'est que il
soit passionné pour que ça ne devine pas
finalement juste un travail mais qui
prennent plaisir parce qu'en plus on est
dans des métiers je pense informatique
mais toujours en évolution donc on doit
monter en compétences en permanence on
pour en parler d'un montant en
compétences mais mais du coup pour
pouvoir en compétences naturellement il
faut aimer ce qu'on fait parce que sinon
c'est compliqué ça devient une démarche
de plus en plus compliquée et avec le
temps qui s'alourdit donc je pense que
c'est
à une chose qu'on peut dire ou candidats
on en a quelques-uns qui vont arriver ce
que les recruteurs responsables
répondent toujours quand ils sont
soliftés spontanément et proprement il y
a pas de raison de ne pas répondre
à des candidats motivés dynamiques et
puis bienveillant Cara voulu dire un mot
oui vous parliez effectivement
d'accessibilité de liens des réseaux
sociaux qui favorisent cette proximité
il y a un levier également un outil qui
peut permettre d'entretenir cette
proximité c'est l'immersion
professionnelle et cette immersion ça
permet dans le cas dans un cadre
juridique sur une convention de stage
qui est signé avec le Pôle Emploi
d'accueillir un demandeur d'emploi dans
le cas d'une découverte des métiers pour
initier une un projet de recrutement une
embauche et donc ouvrir aussi les portes
de l'entreprise à de potentiels
candidats mais ça permet effectivement
peut-être d'accompagner des transitions
professionnelles et peut-être de
récupérer ensuite la compétence à
l'issue peut-être d'un parcours de
formation mais également de détecter des
potentiels et donc ça c'est aussi un
service qui a votre main qui a votre
disposition et accueillir de manière
régulière des candidats c'est aussi
mettre en visibilité votre entreprise
vos besoins vos projets communiquer sur
votre marque en employeur et permettre à
des candidats de se projeter dans du
réel
allez on va conclure ce premier plateau
tout simplement comment recruter en 2023
comment vous allez assurer ces
recrutements et est-ce que vous pouvez
déjà partager peut-être des fois sur
lesquels vous recrutez à l'heure
actuelle alors des postes on en a on en
a quelques-uns en cours des
administrateurs systèmes et réseaux des
commerciaux des postes aussi supports
tels que comptable assistante
commerciale donc ça c'est les postes qui
sont disponibles aujourd'hui dans le
groupe c'est 150 postes ouverts
aujourd'hui partout en France mais voilà
nous on en a une dizaine dans dans les
Yvelines pour appeler Coignières et
Asnières Versailles Versailles
Boulogne-Billancourt voilà et
j'en oublie une autre Saint-Cloud c'est
la dernière en date alors comment
recruter en 2023
la thématique je suis pas sûr d'avoir
toujours les bonnes recettes mais en
tout cas qu'est-ce que je fais au
quotidien c'est effectivement on les
annonce on a des candidatures et c'est
tous les jours c'est quotidiennement
regarder toutes les candidatures qui
arrivent parce que dans candidature là
il y a peut-être notre futur pépite donc
ça c'est un premier point et même si on
n'a pas prévu de recruter immédiatement
bah parfois on recrute on va dire un
petit peu plus parce qu'on sait qu'on en
aura besoin dans les dans les semaines
ou dans les mois qui suivent et puis
c'est aussi comme c'est Madame en fait
c'est d'accueillir on est l'entreprise
qui est très accueillante donc nous on a
on prend beaucoup de stagiaire dès la 4e
pourquoi et on fait découvrir
l'entreprise on fait découvrir notre
métier est-ce que parfois ça crée des
vocations et donc c'est effectivement ce
que vous disiez c'est en accueillant de
bah des stagiaires dès la 4e et puis
jusque au bac + 5 et puis parfois en
reconversion également ça permet de
montrer l'entreprise
ça permet de montrer notre métier et
puis encore une fois parfois de voilà de
déclencher quelques quelques belles
réussites et quelques recrutement on a
un collaborateur on a fêté ses 20 ans il
y a quelques semaines mais il est arrivé
chez nous par un stage voilà il y a 20
ans en reconversion donc un exemple de
l'immersion professionnelle exactement
Jean-Paul oui bon dans la même logique
on est adepte depuis très longues années
de j'irai de l'alternance et donc on est
certain alternants qui finalement à bout
de leurs achats sont restés et dont sont
devenus des sont devenus des
collaborateurs recrutement c'est en
fonction de l'évolution de l'activité et
de nous effectivement de nos besoins et
puis actuellement on est effectivement
là on a recrute on vient de défectuer un
recrutement avec une personne en j'irai
en assistance commerciale qui démarre le
2 janvier et on a en ce moment un
recrutement également ouvert pour un
poste de technicien atelier voilà dans
une fabrication donc sur trappe Kevin
2023 recrute côté eurica des consultants
innovations et avec airbnadium on ne
recrute des développeurs web on est
vraiment en recherche et bon alors la
stratégie on a pas été très bon en 2022
mais je pense que avec l'expérience les
collaborations avec les partenaires
territoriaux le Pôle Emploi
Sky emploi
51 Yvelines voilà ça marche plutôt bien
au big to avec Sky emploi où on a
recruté notre dernière collaboratrice et
ça se fait plutôt bien va passer et avec
Pôle emploi c'est des trucs qui ont
marché voilà l'idée pour nous c'est
d'aller vraiment soit vers nos
partenaires soit directement dans le
berceau dans les écoles pas des stages
ou l'alternance juste pour préciser le
pictour c'est un événement qui est
organisé par BPI France en collaboration
avec 50 ans en Yvelines qui s'est tenu
au Vélodrome national je crois que
c'était en septembre dernier le 20
septembre dernier et justement ils
organisaient le l'événement phare de 50
ans en Yvelines le empiste pour l'emploi
le gros job dating organisé par 50 ans
Virginie votre avis sur comment recruter
en 2023 alors je sais que vous c'est
plus différent vous avez une position
différente de formatrice donc en fait
justement on en parlait ce que
effectivement on accompagne aussi
notamment Axel dans la communication
numérique en fait je crois qu'il y a une
chose qui est importante c'est que dans
les annonces on peut pas toujours
véhiculer des choses hyper des éléments
hyper essentiels pour des candidats qui
est l'histoire de l'entreprise ces
valeurs ses engagements et moi je
recommande à tous les dirigeants d'un
carnés leur entreprise sur les réseaux
sociaux aussi et transmettre ça à
travers leur histoire à travers leur
parcours à travers leurs anecdote et du
moins en tout cas de pas rester sur des
annonces très froides et travailler
cette marque employeur à travers les
émotions parce que derrière il y a des
humains et en fait on rejoint un patron
c'est pas pour rien le thème de
l'émission C'est je partage son avis
parce que je parlais d'envie des l'envie
des candidats entre entreprises il faut
aussi leur donner envie et ça c'est
essentiel et je vais découvrir par
exemple Virginie parce que c'est très
récent ça a monté une dizaine de jours
ou effectivement on a travaillé ensemble
sur notre communication numérique
d'oppositionnement linkedinine etc et en
incarnant et en faisant les choses de
façon beaucoup plus
personnelle la part du dirigeant moi
j'ai découvert par exemple surprises que
mes potes qui aujourd'hui faisaient
200-300-300 vues posent bien travailler
ensemble et après de 6000 vues du jour
au lendemain donc ça fonctionne donc
j'ai pas encore le candidats
en 2023 peuvent passer donc plus sur les
réseaux sociaux pour conclure Kiara Pôle
emploi du coup les actions font
poursuivre en 2021 alors les actions
vont poursuivre en 2023 ils vont
s'intensifier avec la mise en place de
mes événements emploi donc chaque pôle
emploi organisera avec votre concours
des sessions de recrutement pour
favoriser cette intermédiation c'est
également l'accès à la formation pour
développer les compétences des candidats
c'est également des semaines dédiées
thématiques pour mettre en visibilité
aussi des secteurs qui recrutent et donc
la semaine du numérique on va démarrer
en janvier par cette semaine du
numérique avec cet ambition cet objectif
de mettre en visibilité les opportunités
du secteur et donc on a besoin de vous
pour voilà pour parler de vos
recrutements de vos entreprises de votre
marque employeur et puis susciter des
vocations merci à vous d'être venu sur
ce plateau pour parler justement des
évolutions et puis de cette conjoncture
qui s'annonce au niveau de l'emploi en
2023 viennent Roland dirigeant de xéphis
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines Jean-Paul
Mignard dirigeant un sol Kevin gifen
joue Eurêka et RD manager et puis Kera
et drief directrice du bureau Pôle
emploi de Rambouillet
[Musique]
alors Virginie vous restez avec moi sur
ce plateau parce qu'on va poursuivre et
passer sur la thématique qui veut être
mon boss dans quelques minutes vous
allez assister à des prises de contact
entre dirigeants d'entreprise et
candidate à des postes alors il y a des
postes autour de l'animalerie des
animaux il y a un poste aussi autour du
management de l'innovation d'ailleurs
peut-être que Kévin reviendra en plateau
vous qui nous suivez sur Linkedin vous
allez assister à cela dans les
prochaines minutes et d'ailleurs on va
commencer déjà à faire par faire
connaissance avec nos candidates qui
nous ont rejoint donc Morgane Morgane
qui est
Morgane pardon votre new excusez-moi
vous vous êtes candidate pour poste pour
le prêt-à-porter ça est-ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter vous présenter en
quelques minutes exactement je m'appelle
Morgane Colling j'ai 22 ans j'habite
dans les Yvelines et je suis passionné
de mode en terme général j'ai fait des
études de modélisme en BTS
les métiers de la mode et du vêtement à
côté de vous Vanina voit le cas bonjour
bonjour alors vous vous êtes candidats
pour parce que vous êtes passionné
d'animaux c'est ça oui c'est bien ça si
vous pouvez vous présenter aussi bien
sûr je me présente Vanina walkin j'ai 23
ans et j'habite à Versailles je suis
depuis toujours passionnée par les
animaux et je veux contribuer à leur
bien-être animal
et enfin Diane Douala oui bonjour Alors
vous c'est plus l'innovation c'est ça
l'innovation la stratégie le management
de façon générale donc je m'appelle
Diane voilà j'ai 24 ans et j'habite à
Versailles et je suis actuellement en
recherche d'un poste en tant consultante
et ça correspond bien à ce que propose
Kevin s'il est bien compris
juste après d'abord parce que en visio
avec nous et justement on a peut-être
des opportunités pour vous en visio avec
nous il y a Frédéric Lorca donc le
directeur de printemps du magasin
Printemps de Westfield Parly de bonjour
bonjour
Alors et puis avec nous aussi il y a
Christelle Bercheny qui est directrice
des ressources humaines au zoo de Thoiry
bonjour
alors vous êtes tous les deux avec nous
on va on va tout de suite s'engager
directement dans ces rencontres entre
les candidates que nous avons en plateau
et puis et puis vous deux opportunités
de candidats pour vous on va commencer
avec vous Morgane alors est-ce que vous
pouvez présenter un peu vos attentes
vous allez le directeur de printemps qui
est en liaison et il vous écoute
d'accord
c'est du direct c'est pas c'est la
première voilà alors
bonjour du coup comme je l'ai dit
précédemment j'ai fait des études de BTS
les métiers de la mode et du vêtement
donc bien évidemment ce que j'aime dans
la vie c'est c'est la mode ça a démarré
depuis toute petite quand ma grand-mère
m'apprenait déjà les bases les bases de
la couture c'est là que j'ai su que je
voulais en faire ma vocation et c'est
comme ça que je suis passée de faire des
vêtements pour mes doudous à faire mes
propres vêtements comme la blouse que je
porte actuellement et je me suis
renseignée sur sur votre entreprise
j'aime énormément ces valeurs j'aime
beaucoup l'aspect aussi historique le
côté implanté dans Paris depuis déjà
depuis déjà le début depuis 1865 donc ça
fait déjà un bon moment que c'est que
c'est en place et
si jamais mon profil vous intéresse
n'hésitez pas à discuter avec moi sur
mon LinkedIn
Frédéric
votre réaction par rapport à cette
présentation et puis c'est de ce profil
c'est très précis très concis on sent
que Morgane est très motivé
effectivement son parcours
son parcours pourrait l'ouvrir certaines
portes au sein du printemps et plus
particulièrement dans mon magasin vu que
nous recherchons aussi des postes
actuellement de visuels merchand dizer
en CDD donc qui
nécessite des notions à la fois de
cynisme
de scénographie et de connaissances du
milieu de la bonne voilà c'est le plein
rush de Noël pour vous je suppose mais
néanmoins vous vous avez des besoins de
recrutement je suppose que ça doit pas
être la priorité en ce moment
c'est si c'est une priorité parmi parmi
tant d'autres mais c'est une priorité
dans la mesure où dès 2023 le magasin
ouvert à
ses portes sur les 52 dimanche donc nous
avons des besoins à recrutement et et le
point concernant la crise des
compétences a été
évoqué tout à l'heure dans votre
émission effectivement il nous manque
pas mal de de postes vacants je peux
vous les citer
aujourd'hui une recherche en
coordinateur une coordinatrice marketing
un manager des ventes des responsables
de boutiques des conseillers de vente un
visuel merchandiser et des postes aussi
en back-office de gestionnaire
administratif ou gestionnaire des
vous entendez ces intitulés de poste ça
vous parle
oui visuelle marchandisor ça me parle
plutôt bien et ça m'intéresse beaucoup
l'entretien ici le début de l'entretien
c'est fait là voilà la rencontre en tout
cas il y a un petit match comme disait
tout à l'heure Kévin il y avait des
difficultés entre les dirigeants
d'entreprises à matcher avec les bons
candidats en tout cas là on sent qu'il y
a des profils un profil en tout cas le
profil de Morgan ne peut être
intéressant pour vous Frédéric Virginie
quand vous voyez des candidats que vous
avez suivi durant toute la semaine
Morgan notamment que là qui vient de
faire sa présentation c'est plutôt
positif mais moi je suis ravi puis je
trouve c'est des belles personnes enfin
je vais passer du coup une semaine avec
elle donc je veux dire que on a parlé
tout à l'heure de compétences mais aussi
de savoir-être et moi je la recommande
vraiment vraiment ok je le dis parce que
le sourire la bonne humeur l'envie la
passion et tout ça ça fait ça joue
énormément je crois dans dans
l'intégration d'une boîte donc Frédéric
pour vous recontacter une adresse mail
un site internet pour que Morgane puisse
prendre contact avec vous après on verra
en coulisse aussi pour les coordonnées
précises
qu'elle me contacte directement sur
Linkedin le plus simple et je vais on va
se connecter de toute façon très
rapidement
tu as cela il y a aussi le LinkedIn du
printemps ou tous les postes sont
tous les postes ouverts sont visibles et
vous pouvez directement rentrer en
contact avec moi sur mon listing
merci beaucoup Frédéric Lorca bon
courage dernière ligne droite
merci bonne fête merci beaucoup merci
pour votre disponibilité
et c'est pas évident on est en direct
n'hésitez pas à par exemple voilà j'ai
Najet qui est sur Linkedin qui commente
sur Linkedin en direct de très belles
perspectives de collaboration
effectivement c'est une première prise
de contact donc on va voir ce que ça
donne mais en tout cas voilà Morgane
vous avez entendu Frédéric Lorca hésité
à aller sur le la page LinkedIn de
printemps ou sur le site internet et
puis on vous donnera ses coordonnées
après en sortant du plateau merci
beaucoup et on passe tout de suite à
Vanina walkin donc on a la directrice
des ressources humaines Christelle
berchenille qui est en liaison avec nous
et puis bah écoutez elle vous écoute sur
vos attentes qu'est-ce que vous attendez
de la part peut-être du zoo de Thoiry
c'est essayer des candidatures
bien sûr donc comme je l'ai dit
précédemment je suis depuis toujours
passionnée par les animaux
c'est depuis que je suis petite et
j'étais entourée d'animaux de chats de
chiens de petits poissons de lapin et
j'ai eu un effet marquant dans ma vie
quand j'étais plus jeune qui du coup ma
bouleversée et c'est depuis ce jour là
que je me suis dit je me suis donné pour
mission de soigner de protéger et de
contribuer au bien-être animal mon rêve
c'est de travailler avec les animaux de
me lever chaque matin avec envie de
pouvoir vivre de ma passion j'ai vu que
d'ailleurs que les autoris c'est un
magnifique parc zoologique avec son
safari mais qui propose aussi des
rendez-vous avec les animaux et les
soigneurs avec le public du coup et
j'aimerais participer à cela donc si
vous voulez on pourra prochainement se
recontacter sur Linkedin merci
votre réaction suite à cette
présentation de de Vanina
et bien Maina semble extrêmement
passionnée et beaucoup dans l'émotion
Catalin quand elle en parle donc nous on
recherche toujours des gens passionnés
et puis c'est un métier extrêmement
difficile puisque vous êtes 90% à
l'extérieur un séjour sur 7 pour prendre
soin de nos animaux faut savoir que ce
sont les animaux qui sont plus dans un
espace sauvage et dans un dans une
posture de sauvage donc c'est beaucoup
d'implication humaine pour le bien-être
de ces animaux et on intervient
quasiment uniquement pour leur bien-être
donc c'est à dire les nourrir faire en
sorte que leur habitat soit propre et
garantir que l'ensemble des normes de
sécurité pour leur sécurité aussi bien
pour celle de nos clients soit effective
donc Valina nous a déjà envoyé son CV il
y a quelques heures donc je suis en
train d'organiser avec justement
l'équipe animalière pour pouvoir
justement la recevoir et peut-être lui
montrer un petit peu tous les métiers
qui existent parce qu'on parle souvent
du métier de soigneur mais il y a 1000
métiers de l'animal et surtout aux
Thoiry aussi bien en termes accueil
clientèle ou pédagogie et vu son
parcours je pense sera intéressant
qu'elle rencontre les acteurs plutôt que
tout de suite se dire on va être
soigneur si je pense qu'il y a plusieurs
métiers qui pourraient l'intéresser on
en parlait tout à l'heure d'ailleurs
avec
la directrice du pôle emploi de
Rambouillet qui qui parlait d'immersion
professionnelle ça vous tenterez vous
une immersion professionnelle justement
pour vous tester voir qu'est-ce que
c'est le quotidien justement aux autres
Thoiry
[Musique]
quel poste vous recherchez à l'heure
actuelle
nous on est en continuant de recherche
aussi bien sur les métiers en lien avec
l'animal donc pédagogie ou soignants
animalier mais également surtout ce qui
est exploitation pour accueillir nos
clients
et aujourd'hui on a aussi des postes
ouverts sur le marketing et le
commercial et bien parfait merci de
d'avoir
pouvoir vous être rendu disponible pour
pouvoir rendre possible cette prise de
contact vous avez déjà pris contact en
fait en envoyant le CV bon bah c'est
bien le principal c'est que ça avance
c'est que vous puissiez vous rencontrer
dans les prochaines semaines pour
potentiellement devenir la nouvelle
collaboratrice une nouvelle
collaboratrice du saute toi et merci
Christelle berchoni Merci à VOUS
directrice directrice des ressources
humaines à bientôt Vanina voilà
justement on va revenir sur cette
initiative de cette semaine de booster
l'emploi via l'outil numérique Virginie
avant star on va peut-être accueillir
quand même présenté
secrétaire général de la CPME des
Yvelines qui a contribué aussi à cette
semaine et à rendre possible cette
émission Virginie comment ça s'est passé
cette semaine est-ce que vous avez
reconnu vos candidates du début de la
semaine où est-ce que il y a une
évolution et
une sacrée révolution parce que dire
mais elles sont vraiment vraiment
j'insiste formidables vraiment je d'un
point de vue main ça a été une semaine
très intense on peut dire que on a filmé
le premier pitch en début de semaine
donc on a l'avant après donc c'est
intéressant voilà et puis surtout
l'objectif était aussi de faire
ressortir cette passion qu'on ressent
bien je sens dans les pitch donc on sent
bien qu'elles ont envie donc moi je suis
très très fière de les voir aujourd'hui
là sur le plateau pour parler un peu du
dispositif en tout cas déjà je remercie
aussi les employeurs qui jouent le jeu
parce que ça se fait comme ça
effectivement début de semaine d'aller
chercher des employeurs qui match avec
les profils des candidats grâce aux
réseaux sociaux ils ont répondu présent
jusqu'à la dernière minute on peut se le
dire jusqu'à ce matin donc vraiment je
les remercie pour avoir pour cette
rendue disponible je remercie aussi la
CPME parce que c'est vrai que le
partenariat c'était aussi de nous aider
plus visibles à trouver des employeurs
parce que c'est un vrai sujet
là où on a aidé sur ce spartenariat
c'est tous les employeurs qui sont
adhérents à la CPME sur le territoire on
les accompagne aussi avec Pôle emploi
avec la paix avec les missions locales
pour trouver les les éventuels de profil
et du coup on recense toutes les fiches
de poste de nos de nos adhérents et
c'est en cela qu'on a permis à Virginie
trouver des employeurs qui recrutaient
actuellement voilà quel concert vous
faites vous à la CPME par rapport
ce phénomène des besoins de recrutement
on a sorti une enquête un peu moins d'un
mois ou sur 3000 chefs d'entreprises
interrogés 1 sur deux recruter sur tous
ceux qui recrutaient on a 93% qui avait
des difficultés à recruter parmi eux il
y a un tiers qui pensait augmenter les
salaires pour éventuellement trouver un
profil et il y en a beaucoup qui ne
trouvaient même en augmentant en
augmentant les salaires avaient des
problèmes à trouver des compétences chez
les candidats donc on a vraiment
beaucoup de difficultés en ce moment et
c'est un vrai problème quelle ville je
vais me tourner vers vous les
principales vous tirez de cette semaine
qu'est-ce que vous avez appris est-ce
que vous pouvez nous raconter un peu
c'était vraiment très enrichissant et
très intense aussi on a appris beaucoup
de choses on a rencontré des personnes
formidables toutes les intervenantes
étaient vraiment incroyable et aussi les
autres candidats on s'est beaucoup
entraîné
entre nous sur nos recherches sur nos
pitchs sur tout ce qu'on a appris on a
ça nous a permis aussi cette formation
de développer nos compétences chacun
individuellement nos compétences sur sur
les réseaux et sur aussi des logiciels
de création donc tel que canevas ou
sinon pour tout ce qui est communication
LinkedIn linkri tout ça
vraiment je recommande je recommande à
100% cette formation qui est juste
dingue
pour votre ressenti sur cette semaine
j'étais loin d'imaginer ce que j'allais
vivre cette semaine tant au niveau des
rencontres au niveau des compétences
professionnelles
c'était juste fun formidable et j'ai
rencontré cinq
amis franchement c'est devenu des amis
pour moi et à la fin j'ai eu un
entretien avec les autres Paris donc
franchement c'était je recommande cette
formation à tous à tous ceux qui veut
trouver un emploi je voulais préciser
que c'est tout à l'heure c'était pas la
RH c'était DG de Thoiry
cette semaine comment elle a été pareil
époustouflante en fait parce que on
arrive on se dit ok on va apprendre sur
Linkedin sur canevas un peu de Peach
storytelling qu'est-ce que c'est OK et
là incroyable des intervenants
passionnés à l'écoute et bienveillante
et sans compter les autres candidats qui
comme elles l'ont bien dit on s'est tout
entraider on s'est soutenu on s'est
apporté des des petits tips en plus ah
ok ceux-là tu le vois comme ça comme si
en fait du brainstorming en direct comme
ça toute la semaine sans compter sur
l'énergie de Virginie aussi qui était
incroyable donc moi je recommande
totalement star tag à tous ceux qui ont
envie un peu de savoir se vendre
autrement et dans la bienveillance on va
demander juste à Kévin de revenir en
place aussi s'il est resté si Kevin peut
revenir en plateau oui bien sûr
on appellera Didier DJ qui recruteur
indépendant après juste on va commencer
avec Kevin parce que Diane vous avez
parlé de Kevin
Kevin on parle de management de
l'innovation Diane voilà qui est
spécialisé dans ce domaine là allez-y
quels sont vos attentes et les Diane
pareil partager vos attentes à Kévin
merci déjà de me donner la possibilité
de rencontrer une quantité de motivée et
dynamique c'est que c'est exactement ce
que nous recherchons des candidats
dynamiques motivés alors nous on fait de
l'innovation du management stratégique
et financer l'innovation ça ça vous
intéresse c'est bien ce qui vous parle
concrètement c'était une offre il y a
les mots clés il y a management
innovation et stratégie concrètement
c'est ma passion c'est ce que j'aime
faire et j'ai toujours aimé apporter des
solutions aux problèmes et je pense que
là dans ce que vous faites c'est tout à
fait ce que je recherche cette très
intéressante alors nous effectivement il
y a pas que le profil technique qui
compte il y a aussi le sens de
l'innovation du candidat sa vision en
termes d'innovation je pense que les
premiers entretiens elles ont été bien
préparés par Virginie et devrait les
passer mais après c'est le deuxième
entretien qui sera peut-être que les
plus intéressants
avec moi pour le coup et en fait la
question qu'on peut poser en général
dans ces entretiens c'est peut-être mais
si je vous demande quel est votre plus
belle innovation des soins des années
par exemple
mon innovation favorite c'est-à-dire
celle que je préfère et que je trouve la
cuisine innovante
je devrais dire Tik Tok Tik Tok pour moi
ça a été un réseau innovant à la fois
par le fait qu'on puisse transmettre ce
qu'on connaît partager des moments un
peu plus fun mais voilà même le présent
de la République s'en sert dans sa
communication et je trouve ça
révolutionnaire sachant ça change de
Linkedin aussi qui est un peu plus pro
et donc pour moi Tik Tok c'est l'une des
meilleures innovations de ces dernières
années Nicolas elle a répondu
spontanément Tik Tok ça brûle que elle a
déjà un point de vue en termes
d'innovation et ben je serai ravi de la
recevoir en entretien pour qu'elle me
présente les atouts des Tik Tok mais
vous pouvez favoris et puis peut-être
une innovation qui fait plutôt une échec
et les a tous les raisons de l'échec de
l'innovation ça pourrait être
intéressant de discuter davantage
vous pouvez prendre le contact
directement ça répond à vos attentes
je m'attendais pas du tout à ça
franchement comme je vous l'ai dit j'ai
commencé la semaine en pensant à canva
et là je tombe sur un entrepreneur qui
est dans le thème qui m'intéresse la
stratégie et l'innovation c'est à dire
trouver le problème de l'entreprise et
comment le résoudre de façon innovante
moi je suis partante pour l'aventure
Virginie c'est beau non alors vraiment
je suis très émue c'est vrai je trouve
ça chouette et encore une fois
on a des belles personnes qui ont qui
ont suivi ce programme avec tous une
très belle histoire et je suis ravie
aujourd'hui qu'elle puisse en
communiquer une partie voilà je dis
aussi on avait perdu des personnes
souriantes qui est important très
optimiste en même temps d'un appareil de
tes qualités donc très très bien je suis
ravie vraiment merci de jouer aussi de
se mettre en face à face en direct comme
ça c'est pas c'est pas un exercice
évident donc
c'est spontanée on est en direct sur la
page LinkedIn de TV 78 reliés aussi sur
la page de star tag l'entreprise de
Virginie l'entreprise spécialisée dans
la formation numérique merci Kevin merci
beaucoup merci bon ben alors prise de
contact dans les prochaines semaines
peut-être un troisième on va pas dire
que c'est un entretien mais le deuxième
entretien donc par des Kevin pour
rentrer un peu plus dans les détails
merci beaucoup Kevin pour votre
disponibilité merci à vous et puis bonne
fête
Kévin merci beaucoup et donc Didier
Ligier recruteur indépendant
en plateau
Didier donc je disais que vous étiez
recruteur indépendant juste vous
présenter très rapidement oui voilà donc
j'ai monté il y a quelques années un
cabinet de recrutement indépendant à
Chatou dans les Yvelines donc plus plus
près du territoire des boucs de Seine et
je me suis spécialisé sur le recrutement
au niveau des PME en local et alors
cette semaine vous avez participer aux
côtés de Virginie à accompagner les
candidates
c'est surtout qu'en fait
Diane profil
j'avais profil des de chacun des
candidats et effectivement Didier s'est
proposé de pouvoir discuter avec Diane
et d'avoir un entretien pour la
conseiller ce qui était plutôt sympa et
très spontané donc visiblement ça a bien
marché et Diane a été ravi des retours
donc c'était l'occasion effectivement de
voilà
finalement vous avez le choix
j'avais le choix et en fait en
échangeant avec Didier au premier abord
c'était vraiment bienveillant et j'ai eu
son retour de recruteur auquel profilé
comme ça il y a peut-être aussi
améliorer ça je comprends ça je
comprends pas et je me dis bah très bien
moi c'était là c'était la première
premier jet donc j'essaie je tente et
puis on verra ce que ça donne et là
enfin il a il a vraiment été il a
apporté sa petite pierre à l'édifice et
j'ai d'ailleurs partagé vos conseils à
tout le monde voilà peut-être se vendre
un peu différemment et ça a été génial
enfin un petit coaching Express comme ça
génial Didier quand vous voyez le
comportement de Diane en fin de semaine
est-ce que c'est la même personne que
vous avez vu peut-être en début de
semaine alors bon je l'ai pas vu en
début de semaine j'ai une discussion
effectivement avec elle hier et je
trouve l'exercice est pas falloir
exercice c'est pas facile parce que le
problème c'est d'être vraiment dans la
cible et pour moi diagnole a vu une
tendance au début quand on a discuté
quand j'ai vu son parcours à ratisser un
petit peu large et c'est un petit peu ce
que font tout le monde y compris les
dirigeants d'entreprises alors qu'en
fait il faut vraiment être cerné il faut
vraiment cerner ce qu'on veut et être
assez précis plutôt que de ratisser un
petit peu plus large donc on sera amené
de toute façon à discuter j'ai deux
trois événements enfin deux trois
contacts sur lequel on pourra être je
pourrais mettre Diane en lien ou en
relation et effectivement l'impact des
réseaux sociaux est très rapide
là-dessus puisque moi je discutais là il
y a deux minutes par LinkedIn avec ma
fille en lui disant il y a une émission
qui passe en direct et elle m'a envoyé
un mot dans la personne qui fait de
l'innovation m'intéresse vous voyez
comme quoi ce lien peut être en direct
qui me disent j'ai des employeurs
présentés donc super et d'ailleurs
n'hésitez pas à sur Linkedin vous qui
nous suivez en direct à demander les
coordonnées ou apprendre contact
directement avec les candidates les
profils sont notamment sur la page
LinkedIn de star tag et bien juste pour
conclure peut-être cette émission en
direct sur Linkedin en un mot me dire
comment vous pourriez qualifier la
semaine que vous venez de vivre la
semaine a été
extrêmement riche vraiment c'est le mot
riche et plein de surprises et donc moi
je recommande pour les prochains
candidats allez chez Star Trek parce que
la pratique la pratique lymphatique et
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui fait qu'on est
sur cette date là Vanina à votre tour en
un mot cette semaine comment vous
pourriez la qualifier même pour vous
aussi personnellement dans votre
recherche elle a été intense et
franchement comment tu as dit c'est la
pratique la pratique la pratique
Morgan la pratique la pratique la
pratique la pratique comme toujours
en réalité c'était une semaine
exceptionnelle vraiment
comme toutes les autres je recommande
beaucoup cette formation vraiment c'est
une formation qui change la vie pour de
vrai Virginie
alors déjà il y a une session début
février effectivement dans les Yvelines
donc n'hésitez pas à vous rapprocher de
l'agence de Sartrouville cette fois-ci
sera un autre endroit je remercie encore
une fois les partenaires vraiment
j'insiste parce que la CPME Pôle emploi
sans Pôle Emploi ça ne pourrait pas
avoir lieu donc et merci aux candidats
qui ont joué le jeu il faut savoir que
tout le monde n'est pas là tout le monde
n'est pas sur le plateau il y a d'autres
candidats qui étaient là cette semaine
donc effectivement on pouvait pas faire
passer tout le monde mais voilà l'idée
c'est que ce sont des sessions quand
même il y a il y a de la place donc
n'hésitez pas à vous inscrire dès
maintenant ça voilà ce sera la prochaine
émission puis on pourra aussi faire le
point sur Que sont-ils devenus et dans
les semaines qui viennent vous allez
voir vous allez voir des petites
capsules vidéo ou chaque candidat va se
présenter et donc on diffusera sur les
réseaux sociaux évidemment donc voilà
n'hésitez pas à suivre la suite des
aventures merci encore Didier d'être
venu en un mot peut-être qualifié ce
type d'initiative sous le recruteur si
vous êtes dit non il peut être que
positif parce que ça leur permet rien
que là effectivement de se présenter
d'apprendre à mieux pitcher à cerner
Skive a rencontré des entreprises et
puis à créer du lien donc oui c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut multiplier
merci à vous merci Virginie encore pour
cette collaboration pour avoir rendu
possible cette émission qui veut être
mon boss c'est inscrit c'est écrit juste
là là
partout c'est écrit partout voilà qui va
être mon boss donc une émission avec des
entretiens d'embauche en direct sur le
plateau de TV 78 merci pour votre
disponibilité mardi merci aussi d'avoir
joué le jeu en tant que candidate voilà
j'espère que on croise les doigts ça va
matcher avec les échanges que vous avez
eu merci beaucoup merci à vous qui nous
avait suivi sur LinkedIn et puis
poursuite la suite c'est les modules
vidéo à regarder sur la page LinkedIn de
star tag merci
[Musique]